thank you to the people who worked so
hard to share
our message who volunteered for us and
what felt like
an endless campaign thank you to the
candidates and members of parliament who
work not just for six weeks but for
three years to earn their community
support
[Applause]
but most importantly thank you to the
many people
who gave us their vote who trusted us to
continue with leading new zealand's
recovery
who back to the plan we are already
rolling out
and to those amongst you who may not
have supported labor
before and the results tell me
there were a few of you
to you to you i say thank you
we will not take your support for
granted
and i can promise you we will be a
party that governs for every new
[Applause]
zealander
and governing for every new zealander
has never been so
important more than it has been now
we are living in an increasingly
polarized world
a place where more and more people have
lost the ability to see one another's
point of view
i hope that this election new zealand
has shown that this is not who we are
that as a nation we can listen and we
can debate
after all we are too small to lose sight
of
other people's perspective
elections aren't always elections aren't
always great at bringing
people together but they also don't need
to tear one another apart and in
times of crisis i believe new zealand
has shown that and so
again i say thank you
this has not been an ordinary election
and it's not an ordinary time
it's been full of uncertainty and
anxiety
and we set out to be an antidote to that
as a nation we needed a plan for
recovery and so that is what we created
we needed an ongoing health response to
the global pandemic
to keep people safe so that is what
we've done and we needed a team
focused absolutely and entirely on new
zealand
and labor absolutely is
[Applause]
tonight's result has been strong
and it is clear that labour will lead
the government for the next three years
[Applause]
and over the next three years there is
much work to do
we will build back better from the
covert crisis
[Applause]
better stronger with an answer to the
many challenges new zealand already
faced
this is our opportunity to build an
economy that works for everyone
to keep creating decent jobs to
upskill and train our people to protect
our environment and address our climate
challenges
to take on poverty and inequality to
turn
all of the uncertainty and hard times
into cause
for hope and optimism it's an
opportunity we have already grabbed
and a plan we have laid out to invest in
the infrastructure
it sets us up for generations to come or
creating
thousands of jobs new state homes to
house the homeless
100 renewable electricity
generation free trades training and
interest-free loans for small businesses
to expand and to thrive
our plan is already in action and
already working
but after this result we have the
mandate to accelerate our response
and our recovery and tomorrow we
start
we know we know
the next few years will not be easy
the last few have not been easy either
but there have been chinks of light that
have shone through even the darkest
of times that light has been
our nation's determination
our support for one another our sense of
resolve
and that light has always been more
powerful
than the most overwhelming darkness
yes policies ideas
and having a plan matters but it will
only be as good as the people that it
works to support
and i cannot imagine a people i would
feel more privileged to work on behalf
of
to work alongside and to be prime
minister for
we will govern as we campaign
positively with optimism about our
future with a relentless
focus on a recovery that brings new
zealanders with us
to deliver long-lasting change now
more than ever is the time to keep going
to keep
working to grab hold of the
opportunities that lay in front of us so
let's
step forward together kahuake
let's keep moving